so what at Reyes comes back to the place
the second time like from the first
chapter the second time in the first
chapter
wait it's like a puzzle box okay from I
don't know oh yeah or no you're thinking
of something else
no you're thinking of a third you mean
the one where a trace didn't come from
no I'm I don't think I've gotten there
yet
I just don't think I'm as far as you
well I know you're not he was the one
that told first told me about it before
I even got there but you must have seen
the that oh yeah he she or it comes back
to wait you can't just say those three
things this is a he or she you know I
don't know we're in it I mean I know
what if he's talking about a show in
sync shut up
I came in - then you gotta war very
skeptical of like sort of the changes
they were making I know I didn't really
have a lot of like desire to play a new
god of war like the old style god of war
but I also really wasn't that convinced
by what I had seen in trailers leading
up to this but I gotta say like this
came out of it grabbed me pretty early
on because it was so different a mine
and if this claw reaches the summit
our goal is neither I don't know about
you guys but I feel like the axe is it
it makes a huge difference in this game
in terms of them both like making it
feel like different from God of War but
also retaining some of that brutality
that it was known for its in like a
different way totally yeah like I think
the big concern with the previous games
combat when people talk about the
previous games I hear people say oh it
was boring
what I think they mean by that is that
it lacks like a depth where it's really
easy to just mash like basic combos in
those previous games yeah play not those
games lacked up I I do still enjoy the
comment of history but you attacks like
in in all directions at all times
yeah it was very easy to just kind of
get into this rhythm of constantly
hitting the button and like oh okay I
kind of spam my way through that fight
and this it's not that it's necessarily
more challenging it's just that it's
more demanding where you really have to
like be on like guard and like pay
attention what you're doing and be very
deliberate in like the combos and
buttons you are pressing I think we're
just like demands more focus yeah there
that's the word how you just deliver it
I mean there's obviously anytime you
have something where like I don't know
you start an attack animation they can't
be interrupted people just compare it to
Dark Souls and I'm not gonna do that but
people are saying that because people
are saying that because obviously there
is more there's more intention behind
what you need to do or at least you need
to consider he moves
and I think with the axe when you're
using it you can attack I mean they're a
runic attacks where you can do like AoE
damage but most of them you're attacking
one person at a time it's like you're
hacking at this blunt router and it's
also that over-the-shoulder camera for
the most part obviously the whole game
is shot from that one camera like the
cutscenes or whatever but the actual
combat I was skeptical of as well
because I didn't think that would work
super well like targeting as I didn't
think I would target people well but it
does and then you know you can Swiss
watch between them like whoever you have
locked on but it really does feel good
and I think immediately in the game it
started to just click right away
there is something here that I feel like
a reestablishes god of or something
totally brand-new but there's also
obviously the open issue world
it's bigger than something like like
Uncharted Lost legacy for example which
gave you like if you pass to deviate
from like the main path but you know
this game kind of opens up a few hours
in and it makes you realize like this is
kind of like up to me to see where I
want to go and that also felt obviously
very different where Kratos was in the
past sort of funneled between like one
crazy big set piece to the next fighting
one God from another this is so much
more about him innit Reyes and just
exploring their own pace of doing their
own thing which I really liked
I guess we need to get back up there but
how follow me lost legacy the hug was
just another area that you you could
explore it and complete different things
in the hub but then once you're done you
moved on yeah this hub it functions much
more like a hub like you come back to it
like a Metroidvania you gather supplies
and then spend money it reminds me of
like resident 4 and its pacing is you
kind of come across these like sandbox
areas whether it's using combat in
different ways or actually exploring
outward but I really like how you get
more attached to this world right away
especially once it opens up and you know
you're gonna be coming back here with
new abilities and new items that can get
you to this secret area or this shortcut
and I think that works really well I
really appreciate the side-missions
flesh I like the sort of like Nordic
mythology aspect of it that's something
the other games were very much steeped
in Greek mythology but they kind of
don't do a good job explaining it it
sort of just assumed you knew who all
these Greek characters were this game
kind of knows that people aren't maybe
as familiar with sort of these myths and
and characters and relationships so you
have these great moments where you know
as they were like on the boat like
Petraeus and Kratos will be talking and
they're all kind of like you kind of
learn a little bit about the world look
at that it's door god of thunder that's
right
I never thought you listen to mothers
both in the Box I Sylvan did did she
speak of one who could feel no pain oh
that's sounds like Balder Balder a
nature God son of Odin and free and Odin
is king that's right
why do you ask you get this real sense
of like the scale of everything that's
happening
all these different like realms yes and
figures and gods it's a big space that
you're in it's not like a massive open
world but even then like there's very
few characters in this game right but
it's the stories they share with one
another that really do make it feel like
it has an existence and like it has a
history to it all those boat rides
specifically it seems so weird to think
of God award is sitting in a boat
rolling across a lake but those moments
actually feel very valuable both for the
things that you see because as you
explore the leg obviously you find these
little nooks and crannies but yeah
primarily like you're saying for the
conversations between a trio some Kratos
keep your expectations low boy spirits
are really useful there's just stuff
that other games would fill with like
repetitive kind of like contextual
dialogue but this is almost like a
series of texts that they are working
their way through like the entire game
they never repeat anything it's always
like a new story based on what's
happening or where they are in the map
and it it fills out like little pieces
of their character in a way like I love
how this game this game doesn't abandon
sort of like the previous games like
fiction at all which is kind of what
worried about is like oh it's gonna be
sort of like a soft reboot type of
situation when it's like it technically
happened but we're kind of ignoring it
instead the game actually very much like
tackles it makes that a part of the game
it's like you know takes a while and it
really pays well again but yeah it's
like really cool subtle stuff like
there's this great bit where you are you
find like this spirit of a Reaver who's
got killed by his son and then like
trace is like why would why would anyone
kill their own dad I just don't
understand that this makes no sense to
me
Kratos just flashback to Korea is that
you can literally keep the game going
and got two or three as long as you're
punching him he's just silent like
kratos doesn't say anything guess I
shouldn't be surprised I did the same
thing to my dad when I was his age he
killed his own father where is he now
those moments of those previous games
like scarred his personality and bred
affected him and they present that in
like really subtle ways that is feels
really rewarding as someone who's played
all of the game right I feel like I'm
getting all this one
we'll pay off well no one would blame
you for thinking Kratos was an utter
dick right based on the B's he was also
like shafted at the very beginning of
the series wait who did not have to be
this way
now it's like he's sort of come full
circle to where he may be he sort of
returned to a bit of you know he's got
his humility back in a way cuz he's got
his son he's got this this kid that he
needs to raise and sort of take care of
and teach that maybe I won't let the
same things happen to you that happened
to me maybe I can be the guiding hand
that leads you down right we just did an
interview with Corey Barr log Eddie and
ruk off or Australia office just he's
talking oh man he said they almost
didn't get the father-son relationship
into the game because Sony higher-ups
thought it would be too complicated like
from a gameplay perspective and just
like storytelling the pool exec and I
really like because it is a continuation
of Kratos story obviously and he's the
main draw as the God of War but if I
understand finally but also with a trace
there he's kind of a stand-in for the
audience cuz he's like he's really
knowledgeable about Norse mythology and
he can read a bunch different language
Kratos always be like boy come read this
boy over here it says his name is Paul
near mother told me about him
a giant warrior made of stone a certain
point of train starts making fun of him
for it but at Reyes is kind of a
stand-in for us in so far as we're
actually discovering the world along
with him and he was like this is it kid
when he's younger so he didn't really
venture out past the house which they
establish early on so that's really cool
and he's always like really excited to
be exploring and with his dad because
like his dad being a sick kid he didn't
really always get to get out that often
well they smell awful your mother called
him scorn Bulls poison magic she was the
one who showed me how to disable them
what it's just funny to think of her
teaching me something
he's a foil to Kratos and my Kratos
doesn't give a [ __ ] about Midgard or
wherever you are obviously he hates gods
because I was like his past but at Reyes
is just like eager to learn all this
stuff and I think he's kind of sitting
right there with us and I can't imagine
the game without that father/son
relation to side missions where anytime
you do a side mission
Kratos like actively doesn't want to do
it
we don't have time for this look boys
shouldn't we get back to well yeah but
then like you can still go do it anyway
and then when you do it it's sort of
like oh I guess we're here we should
help them and the crisps okay no it's
always justify as if by saying oh we'll
just get better resource just get better
resource but I like I like that back and
forth there's something about that
dynamic that I think is like really fun
don't correct this is not a debate
you must learn focus our journey need be
your only concern well what if thinking
out boss I don't seem to know a little
about the lake and how does that help us
with our goal we won't know unless we
ask well I'm really really impressed
with how how well I mean it was really
Herculean task no pun intended you went
to like take on the old trilogy of games
plus you know change Olympus goes to
Sparta to take that on and also I can
acknowledge that but at the same time
pretty much do like a like mechanic like
that in terms of its gameplay because it
is a reboot almost and they kind of
balance those two things and so far like
you know as the early hours I think do
really well it's pretty impressive I
really like how you know Santa Monica
has set it up for the rest of the game
yeah it's cool both from a perspective
of being a reboot but also just as a
game of 2018 like I haven't touched kind
of war since god of work - maybe I
played a little bit of three but I don't
feel like I've missed out on anything
like I feel like Kratos really
represents a specific point in time in
video games and like we've definitely
come a long way and this is sort of like
the like the best example of what we
expect from like a first party game
today and it was just done news just
made so well and by that I mean like
lots of money lots of time and talent
was put into this and seems like it's
clearly paid off because the foundation
is really that strong
[Music]